Yeah.
Last time on comp top cold war
computers were showing real promise at
translating Russian into
English Georgetown University
stage to successful tech
demo and the press was impressed. Times
were good for machine translation. Aye.
Aye. Aye. Okay. Now that we're back,
the money starts rolling in because if
the public support something politicians
can't lose by throwing money at it,
but people started taking
sides round one fight.
In this corner you had your
linguistically minded perfectionist.
They wanted to feed computers,
all the detailed grammatical
rules about every language.
And in this corner there where your
brute force crowd brute force or is,
we're all about the evidence.
You set computers loose on real sentences
and they should be able to find the
patterns on their own.
Unfortunately,
progress from both sides just wasn't
living up to the bold claims made after
Georgetown and the public.
They started to notice in 1962 hypers
ran an article titled the trouble with
translation and with a title like that,
you know,
it was going to be fair and
objective. The, uh, author.
Recall the demonstration of
machine translation where
the computer was given the
scriptural nugget. The spirit is
willing, but the flesh is weak.
The output we are told is laughable.
The liquor is holding out all right,
but the meat has spoiled.
I just want to pause for a moment.
The dymo reported there didn't happen,
but this story and Harper
is really illustrates how
far machine translation had
fallen a few years earlier.
Those exact same reporters were just
heaping praise on it and now it was the
butt of their magazine jokes.
The scientist's stepped in
for some damage control.
Do you remember Bar Hillel? Our first
full time machine translation man,
he argued that our expectations
were just unreasonable.
Natural language could be ambiguous
and computers can not handle ambiguity.
We shouldn't expect them to
translate languages for us.
We should just get them to help
us translate for ourselves.
Translating languages was way more
complex than even the experts could have
guessed. It was a literally turning
out to be harder than rocket science.
Now in the face of souring public opinion,
the u s government, because again,
they only like throwing
money at popular things.
They commissioned the Alpac Josh,
is that a Lama? Wait, no, sorry.
It's not a Llama.
It's actually an elite group of seven
experts tasked with deciding the
usefulness or uselessness of machine
translation and computational linguistics
as a whole. That's quite a
task. Their verdict. Oh, we'll,
we'll get into that. But first there's
something you need to understand.
Throughout the history of
artificial intelligence,
people get sold on promises far beyond
their wildest dreams and it happens so
often that there's a term for it,
the Ai hype cycle,
and when things go wrong,
the chill sets in a chill
with lasting effects.
It's called an AI winter, and no amount
of jackets protect you from that chill.
So the verdict,
the 1966 ALPAC report concluded that we
do not have useful machine translation
and there is no immediate or predictable
prospect of useful machine translation.
Ouch.
Computer as it turned out,
were twice as expensive as human
translators and they were doing way,
way worse. The officials were convinced
and machine translation was defunded.
The first AI winter set in
computers and language
obviously had a rough start,
but I promise it gets better.
Eventually subscribe,
go eat your Borscht and uh,
write some code chunk.